now we go to madison wisconsin
samantha joins us there samantha how can
we help
hi guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's going on
so i'm just kind of stressing out i
guess i stress out over money a little
too much
um but i guess i could say i'm on baby
step four right now
um but i've kind of been skipping over
and just like tackling my mortgage like
i obsess over a little bit
um so i've been throwing
an x 100 a month on top of our normal
payment
um how much again good and
what's that how much are you how much
are you throwing extra on it
1500 a month okay 1500 a month our
regular payment is
13 and then you know basically anything
i left over between my husband and i
throw in about 1500 after everything's
said and done perfect um
my issue is i'm only throwing in six
percent to my retirement
and my husband is throwing in 11. um
and i guess now i'm faced with a
situation that we have baby number two
coming
um in february and my daycare is about
to go up
way up to about 22 000 a year
um so i'm just trying to figure out if
so it's going to cut my extra payment
down by over half like it's going to go
down to
like 680 or something like that
i'm trying to figure out if i'm doing a
step strong note if i just need to
relax and focus on my 401k
and just do what i can extra to my
mortgage
or if i should keep pounding out my
mortgage i just worry about it because
we do want to
get a bigger house i would hope in the
next five years because
we have two kids now how much is left on
your mortgage
we have 130 000 left we only have about
um 70 000 in it right now
okay been there for like four years well
anthony's going to give you advice here
but i'm going to answer your question
you are doing it wrong there's a reason
why dave ramsey has the baby steps that
are in succession
and so you need to do them the way dave
tells you because you're in good shape
yeah anthony okay uh let's dive deeper
here samantha
uh because i want to know why
you said that you're you're making extra
payments so
you can eventually move into a bigger
house
did i hear you correctly yes and so do
you all want to pay this house off to
rent it or do you want to pay this house
off to use all the equity to go buy
another house which one is it
i just want to have a ton of equity so i
have like such
like basically i want to be able to buy
a house and have less of a mortgage than
what i have now
with a nicer home okay because i just
hate that
okay listen i totally get it we hate
that as well um
so here's the thing baby steps 4
you guys who are listening right now
where samantha is at is
pretty much investing investing 15
of all your income so samantha right now
what's you all's household
income we're before taxes we're at about
a hundred thousand a year
okay so you all need to be investing 15
of that
okay okay and so that's the very first
thing
and then you have kids are you are are
you already investing into their their
college experience like at 529 or
anything like that
not like that no yeah so you need to
take care of these two things
the mortgage is an asset all right and
so
you're trying to make so much payments
towards that but honestly
you can sell that house and and use that
equity to go buy
something but you are missing out on
your retirement
you are missing out on setting your kids
up properly to go to go to school
i want you to take care of those two
things and if you got those two things
going
and you still want to aggressively go
after your mortgage that's perfectly
fine
but right now your retirement is very
important
your house is going up in equity okay
but you're losing out on money by not
investing 15 okay and so what i really
want you to focus on right now is just
slow down on the mortgage payoff right
now
going ahead and beef up your retirement
go ahead and
open up a 529 because you sound like
you're such a loving
uh parent a loving mother and you want
the best for your kids
you can show that to them by going ahead
and investing into the college yep
samantha
do you feel like you and your husband
are topped out on your earning
abilities no yeah of course not
samantha you got 50 you got over 50
equity in your house now you don't have
that much
left do the baby steps the way that dave
tells you to do them because
now you're looking at the holistic
long-term you're only looking at one
piece of the long-term puzzle and it's
because you're amazing we're not getting
on you
you've got drive i love that you want to
pay that house off
you know what you will but you've got to
do this the right way you've got to take
care of the daycare
and you've got to take care of the
long-term investing strategy
and then you got to save for the kids
college the house will be there the
house will come
but you're already doing really really
well on equity so just relax a little
bit
and get this thing in order okay you're
doing great you got this
okay all right all right good deal i
love it
you know here's the thing that i think a
lot of people need to hear hear us say
for clarity
baby steps one through three are done in
that order one two three
baby steps four through seven you can do
them simultaneously all at the one time
but you still want to go ahead and make
sure that you're fully funded
into your retirement before you start
aggressively so let's say for an example
you are
doing baby steps number four fully you
could be doing that
while paying off your mortgage if you
don't have kids that's right so it's
like you can do all four of them at the
same time but you don't want to go after
your mortgage and skip
over your investments and skip over your
retirement so
um i love her heart her passion oh yeah
you know she's like i hate that well we
hate that too
we want you to pay off and be weird and
ha that that mortgage paid off but at
the same time
we love you so much that we want you to
retire inspired
well there's a reason why you asked the
question you know samantha do you and
your husband do you feel like you're
capped at your income
growth and the answer you heard how
quickly she answered she's like no
so that's the answer you go back we get
baby step
four fully fun you get that 15 of both
you and your husband
we start working on saving for the kids
and then we go all right
ah man can't pay the house off fast
enough means i can't buy that bigger
house that i want with that extra
bedroom and the room over the garage and
all the things and i get that there's
nothing wrong with that desire let that
desire
drive you but you've got to have the
discipline
alongside of the desire that's the issue
because if you don't have the discipline
alongside of the desire the desire
wins and that's when we start to cut
corners
and we make bad decisions and so uh the
issue here is is
this couple needs to sit down together
this weekend and they need to say you
know what
how do we increase our income how do we
help each other grow
professionally and as we increase that
income now we take that increase of
income
and we throw that at the house and now
we're really cooking you know so you
just gotta have the full
big picture not just one part of the
picture love it if you're looking at a
picture frame folks of your future
don't get stuck in one corner you gotta
look at the whole picture
that will help you focus on what you
need to focus on